In the lucky search problem, we have 3 inputs.
The index, which is a hash table of all the keywords in the pages in which they appear.
We have the ranks, which rank each page based on the URank algorithm
that we discussed in lecture.
And then we have the keyword we are searching for.
The output is going to be the highest ranking page with that keyword.
The steps to solve this can briefly be summarized as follows.
We're going to go through every page that contains the keyword,
and we're just going to find the page with the maximum rank.
So we're going to find a maximum.
It sounds pretty simple, but it's actually a few lines of code.
So let's go right to the ID.
So the first thing we're going to do is get the pages from the index with that keyword.
If there aren't any pages, then we're going to return none,
and if there's at least 1 page, we're going to say for now the best_page is the first one.
And we're going to iterate through each page in the pages list,
updating our best_page accordingly.
So if the rank of the candidate page, the page that we're iterating through,
is greater than the rank of our best_page, we're going to update our best_page.
Once we're done, we're going to return the best_page.